let's start with authority and
responsibility which is a topic that has
been talked about a lot because some of
those short clips on tick tocks of
Andrew Tates got pulled out and he
claims they were taken out of context
there's a lot of discussion that's been
around that so let's go to 1756 Tyler
and let's have Alyssa
Pierce if a woman comes to me and says I
want you to keep me safe she is handing
me Authority for her safety but do you
understand the difference between having
authority over somebody and somebody
giving you permission to have authority
completely I never said what is
consensual and one isn't but why are we
pretending I do unconsensual things
because you literally say I must have a
degree of authority I have to have some
Authority and the point only if I'm
responsible for her safety if I'm not
responsible position if your position
now is that with her permission I would
like to have authority when we go out at
night to protect it that's a diff that
was always my position that's not what
you said but that was always my position
so again I simply say to you do you it
is what I said do you wish you'd phrase
it a different way no because we're
talking about long format copy where I'm
talking about a woman who's come to me
and said you're so here's the disconnect
and this will happen throughout the
interview and I think that with Tate on
this issue this has happened a lot
people hear the authority regardless as
to whether you agree with it or not
people hear the authority and
responsibility argument and they assume
that he's talking about something
oppressive that he's talking about
something that's not consensual and that
he's saying essentially I am going to
have authority over women meaning I'm
going to Bar the door shut I'm going to
make all the decisions and that's what
it means by Authority that's that's not
what he's saying what he's talking about
are paradigms that exist where men and
women get into relationships and women
defer some of that authority to men
because they expect men to protect them
and to take care of them for example a
woman enters a relationship and says
listen I expect you to provide I expect
you to put a roof over my head I expect
you to pay the bills I expect you to to
physically protect me and to learn how
to use a firearm and to know your
self-defense and if there's an intruder
to protect me and our children
and in turn I am going to defer some
Authority on something so if the guy
then turns around and says okay well
then I don't want you walking around you
know this neighborhood at night that's
dangerous because I'm given the
responsibility to protect you and I
can't do that if you're doing that that
woman then decides okay cool
that's what he's talking about now you
don't have to like that Dynamic for
yourself if you're a female and you're
listening you don't have to like that
Dynamic for yourself if you're a male
but what we are talking about here is a
consensual decision and that word
Authority reads as oppressive to people
who can't relate to a dynamic like that
being appealing to them
so this becomes an emotional reaction to
the argument instead of just saying
that's not a dynamic that would interest
me they they don't do that they they
label it as oppressive because that's
how the modern world has labeled that in
the same way you'll hear a lot of
religious people by the way talk about
the man of the house there's a Biblical
interpretation of the man of the house
and what that means that's not relatable
to people in 2022 in large part they
can't understand it it's like it's a
sign of Oppression just keep in mind
though he's saying this is by choice
this is elective this is not oppressive
by Andrew Tate's definition of what he
meant okay let's go to 1913.
poor Tyler understanding would you tell
an 18 year old boy you don't have
authority over women absolutely you
would say that unless a woman comes to
him and says you're responsible for my
safety please make sure keep me safe
about that Andrew Tay I can sign up to
well then we agree yeah but I don't
agree with what you said before because
you're taking a sound bite from a
two-hour but you haven't been taken out
of context because I read you the entire
sentence it's very you've ignored all
the contexts around the sentence my
friend okay so again we get back to this
conversation about what's going on on
YouTube what's going on on tick tock we
unfortunately live in a world where this
stuff's going to get chopped up there
are times when I myself on my own show
on this platform
we have a team that cuts you know shorts
and short clips where a short will be
cut and I'll say on my own I'll say you
know what we need a little bit of
context before or a little bit of
context after so we add it in we add it
in because we want to provide that
someone else isn't going to give me the
benefit of the doubt they're going to
chop up something I say here it would be
very easy to come into this show
particularly because I say a lot of
stuff that's I push the envelope to come
in here and chop stuff up this is a
reality of the world that we're living
in right now it's not just happening to
Andrew Tate it's happening to everybody
so we need to evaluate that and
recognize this is how people make money
with these little sound bites and that's
where we are so he's not gonna even if
he had caveat some of the stuff we're
going to talk about today even if he had
said
you know I want to be clear this is not
an oppressive structure I can guarantee
you someone would have chop that out
because it it would ruin the cliff for
them they want outrage they want you mad
they want you fired up that's the whole
goal if you want to watch the full
episode you're going to click right here
and if you want to ask me a question one
on one you want to do a one-on-one
FaceTime with a group of your friends
whatever you want you need to download
right now click right here and let's get
talking
thank you